it started off relatively simple with
something you've got very recently as
have a look at this log equation you had
to convert it to this quadratic very
easy to factorize you just had to notice
this pair of restrictions and of course
we talked about this before that
execrated 0 is kind of inverted commas
more restrictive than x is greater than
negative 6 so therefore you've got it
voca x is equal to 3 only so there's a
mark okay let's have a look at question
2 this is reaching back to your work on
binomial this we ought to be able to
expand without anything further than
this look you've got one out the front
so you know it contributes nothing all
you need to think that is that 1331
you've got root 5 you've got root 5
squared and then you've got root 5 cubed
right so you can see there are my there
are my integers and here are my rational
part and there are my irrational parts
so there's your eight and five minutes
only and again it's one more question 3
um let me just say question 3 um as an
original question it really this is the
real question this is the real question
right and you can do this without part 1
you don't need part 1 to help you part
ones meant to be a big flashing sign
clue okay you got to pop one apart to
use them so it's apple of a power line
it's easy you just do your straight
forward expansion okay you take out your
factor do remember it says it says sure
right so you really ought to include a
line like this I really think that line
is important I wouldn't necessarily
deduct marks for it but if you went
straight here like this slide
demonstrates no understanding because
it's there in the question right so
therefore to get to that and you're
trying to show you understand there's a
is really sort of one point here for
having recognized the answer
and in the second point unless IDs are
marks because you might be given one
mark for this question but the second
one is for actually doing the
factorization and the factorization
shouldn't jump straight away you're
trying to show you know you're 11 I know
your instinct is to discuss how are you
went in it you will get that time let's
just try boo through okay can I save
your questions the MRAP is that ok ok
now when you get to part two because of
what you've done in part one like you've
established this result all you need to
say is that in this specific case you've
got that 10 a 10 B part there be equal
to negative 1 that's all you need to do
in this particular case this is true so
you got 1 plus negative 1 over here
which is 0 so this whole part vanishes
now I want to make a note of this third
because I've got a pointer over here
where does this come from because it's
an important part of this result and it
could have been this is not but it could
have been a a show question and then you
actually have to you can't just pull
this out of nowhere so let me show you
where I pulled it from ok and B are both
angles ok you know that B is a cute but
you don't well you know a is not reflex
but that's about all you know about it
because you can't say is obtuse why can
you not say that all you know is the A's
between B and 180 be could be one degree
in which case a could be two degrees so
they could both be acute angles and that
could be fine so where do I pull this
restriction from have a look at these
two restrictions you've been given
you're given this and you're sorry that
should you be you're given this ok now I
put these two together to get a
relationship between a and B I could use
either want us by starting point but I
kind of feel like this one's easier I
want a minus being here somewhere I want
to know what restrictions apply on a
minus B ok because you can see over here
on the left-hand side that's the angle
that I'm working with so i would need to
know
where that's defined okay I feel it the
easiest place to get a minus B out of
this pair of inequalities is here comes
what would I do to this line it's
actually a pair of inequalities right
down I would take away be from every
part of this inequality right so I would
this is what run down I would get B
minus B a minus B and 180 minus B you
came with that so therefore we got near
10 I've got a minus B which is the angle
that I want okay now over here on the
right I could just leave that as it is
okay but keep in mind that all i know
about be like over here it could be
0.0000 000001 right which would make
this like 170 nine point nine nine nine
nine nine nine in other words
practically speaking it's still less
than 180 degrees right like there's no
actual part that I can take off of that
so this is still true taking a baby
doesn't actually change this 180 because
be could be always zero so this can be
almost 180 which exactly what the
Equality already says okay well it could
be but I don't know that fortress for
certain so I can't say if it were 89
that I would know that this would be a
hundred and sorry this would be ninety
one wonders but i don't know that i
don't know that so i can't say it all I
really know is this that as it turns out
okay that would still be okay because if
i use this restriction let's figure out
what caused looks like what does it look
like between nor than 180 it's up it
looks like this it's half of the cycle
isn't it right so even if i did bring it
down all the way up to 91 okay there's
only one solution to that equation when
is this equal to 0 and the answer is
when it's 90 great okay so that's where
I get that solution from there is one
solution and only once
to this because of the domain
restriction you need to bring that in
right so that's a really crafty question
there's not a lot of working to it as
you can see but there is a lot of logic
you need to apply